c'est quand même dingue parce que dans
une émission entière de 2h30 vous rendez
compte que le plus celui qui parle le
plus 4 minutes on a additionné c'est pas
des vannes on a additionné c'est
incroyable pas 4 minutes 17 ce sont les
gens les personnes les mieux payés du
monde
pour 4 minutes de travail non mais bon
est-ce qu'on ce sont des vrais chiffres
les gars c'est hallucinant ça veut dire
que vous ne laissez pas beaucoup parler
en fait
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle non mais c'est vrai non mais
c'est fou parce qu'en fait quand vous
additionnez regardez ça fait 16 16 + 9
25 + 5 30 minutes sans la à peu près
tous ensemble 30 minutes dans l'émission
C'est vrai 30 minutes tous additionner
30 minutes de mission et c'est ça en
fait hein parce que l'émission durant à
peu près 2h30 par les 30 minutes et le
reste du temps c'est vrai que vous
laissez les autres parler et c'est vrai
que quand les grands-parents les petits
se taisent voilà
on va voir qui parle le plus avec 4
minutes 17
celui qui est ton numéro hein
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est celui qui a le plus la
voix de merde
[Rires]
le contraire de The Voice allez en
numéro 2 c'est avec 4 minutes 10 c'est
derrière gilbertez
l'esprit
dans ma télé
que je faisais quoi deux émissions sur 4
de bonne ou un truc comme ça
100% d'émission au top depuis le
septembre
en troisième position j'irai Géraldine
vous êtes sur le podium
vous pouvez en plus passer Gilles dans
un mouchoir de poche et la 4e vraiment
c'est une femme
avec 4 minutes si vous nous rejoignez
sachez que c'est leur temps de parole
par émission vous rendez compte ou pas
celui qui parle le plus dans l'émission
parle 4 minutes 17 quand on a vu ça on
s'est dit mais pourquoi on les paye
vraiment Raymond 4 minutes c'est propre
4 minutes net pas une seconde de plus
c'est la radio
pour me dire que c'est
[Rires]
le 5e chroniqueur dans ce match
sentir pas mal du tout c'est Daniel
Moreau
3 minutes 51 et elle est intégrer les
imposture
8 9 10 vous allez voir vous allez voir
vous allez voir je les ai les 8 9 10
vous allez voir vous allez voir 3
minutes 50 elle est juste dernière dans
le Moreau elle arrive toujours une
seconde après même chez les mecs c'est
Valérie Benaim
a
position et après on va rentrer dans le
dans le tiercé
3 minutes 12 c'est Delphine
[Applaudissements]
parce que elle a quand même un ou une
qui parle une minute 17 dans l'émission
non mais rendez-vous compte le cas ne
vient pas à la limite ne vient pas chez
toi non mais c'est reste chez toi reste
chez toi
je pense que vous avez une petite idée
chez vous
c'est
au sein de la table
sur les mauvais élèves là ça me fait
beaucoup de peine c'est Guillaume
avec deux minutes 55 je vous jure que ce
sont les vrais temps est-ce que les
bâillements sont pris en compte
[Applaudissements]
il te reste pas grand chose et là qui
est dernier qui est dernier il reste ça
c'est que ça se joue entre Béatrice et
Benjamin Castaldi
cette semaine
position si vous avez une neuvième vous
aurez forcément la dernière
en 9e position
[Applaudissements]
je vous le jure je vous le jure que ce
n'est pas truqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et il est content
et il est content extrêmement content
de moto virer
Benjamin Castaldi parle une minute 17 on
a fait vraiment on a pris toute une
émission on a chronomètre à chaque fois
qu'il parle on arrête on a et en fait
dans toute une émission c'est incroyable
c'est tout bout à bout là il a dit c'est
incroyable ça peut être une seconde
une minute 17 ça dépend des thèmes
d'émissions parce que parfois il est
très très utile quand on parle des stars
de gens qui sont dans les chèques
ou qui ont non mais si c'est vrai ou qui
on peut plus de cartes bleues tout ça il
est génial bien sûr et quand on est dans
l'actu ouais ou quand on parle voilà ça
dépend c'est une minute 17 là c'est les
chiffres de cette semaine
j'ai fait un calcul je parle très peu
mais dès que je parle il y a un nombre
de reprises sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi les gens revois parce qu'ils
comprennent pas ce que tu dis donc
extrêmement rentable pour l'image de la
chaîne tu sais à toutes plusieurs fois
les gars combattants
mais voilà Benjamin Castaldi bravo
franchement
vous êtes fiers je suis extrêmement fier
plus les semaines passent tous les jours
passent et plus je vous vois et plus je
mets quoi
la prouesse c'est que c'est celui qui
parle le moins que le mieux payé déjà ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est fou ça va
vraiment le revoir
mais vraiment mais vraiment et je ne
rigole pas on va vraiment le revoir
et sinon Gilles moi je suis surpris
d'une minute 17 parce que j'aurais
jamais pensé que vous déplacez les 30
secondes
apparemment apparemment tu connais sa
femme parce qu'elle a dit exactement la
même chose
merci en tout cas à vous on le refera ça
fait le en tout cas ça ne parlez pas
pour ne rien dire juste pour être bien
classé
j'ai faim